what's good everyone Michael coming to
you live from CES 2018 and I'm at the hi
Perkins suite checking out what they got
and longtime Nintendo fans are in for a
treat the first thing we have to show
here is the Ultra GB which essentially
is a Game Boy it's modeled after the
Gameboy pocket and it takes on original
Gameboy cartridges
it's a work in progress for now it has
an aluminum frame and has teal
backlighting but as hyper Caine works on
this project more and more there will be
other features such as full RGB
backlighting also USB c-type charging
and stereo audio output because of the
stereo output that is coming to the
Ultra GB chiptune artists can also uses
to create chip tunes I got hands-on with
the Ultra GB and I was actually playing
pokemon blue and it works just as I
remember when I had my original Gameboy
the aluminum frame does make it heavier
than the Gameboy pocket but in terms of
ergonomics it is exactly as I remember
spot-on now this does look a lot bigger
than most handheld gaming devices today
but it does take Super NES Super Famicom
and PAL cartridges look at that so you
have your SNES cartridge sticking out
the back here because of high Perkins
pin perfect technology it does stay in
place perfectly fine and you can wiggle
the cartridge around and it's not gonna
mess up your game at all
so it's a neat way to play our original
SNES cartridges on the go it also has
all the features of the original SNES
controller and also has two SNES
controller ports so you can play two
player games with somebody else in terms
of battery it charges through micro USB
and can last up to ten hours as someone
whose first console was the SNES playing
this brought me back to those days as it
plays these games near perfectly games
can be played on the Super Why SFC in
either 4x3 or 16x9 intend else which
from 1990 so that was a few of the new
things that hyper kent is showing off at
CES 2018 make sure you stick to game
spot for all our coverage
thanks for watching
[Music]